[موسيقى]
مشاهدي العربيه اهلا وسهلا بكم الى هذه
المقابله الخاصه مع رئيس مجلس الوزراء
الباكستاني شريف حضرت رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني امضاء حتى اليوم تسعه اشهر ضمن
ولايته الرئاسيه خلال هذه تسعه اشهر هناك
تحديات كبيره تواجه باكستان اقتصاديه
وسياسيا داخليا وخارجيا اهلا وسهلا بك
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي اختارتك
اول وجهه لزيارتك الرسميه بعد تعيينك في
مجلس الوزراء كيف وفي ايطار تضع العلاقه
مع المملكه التي وقفت الى جانب باكستان
منذ زمن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
المتحده حيث تجمع علاقه الاخوه بين
السعوديه وباكس ليس فقط منذ ولاده باكستان
بل منذ قرون نفس الشيء ينطبق على الامارات
العربيه المتحده حيث انه قبل ولاده
باكستان واستقلالها عن الهند الملايين من
المسلمين كانوا يعيشون هناك في شبه القاره
وكانوا ياتون لزياره هذه المنطقه عبر
البحار وعلمتني الجمال والذهاب الى مكه
المكرمه والمدينه المنوره فهذه العلاقه
بين دولنا الشقيقه علاقه فريده من نوعها
عديده
الامارات العربيه المتحده بايطار تضع هذه
الزياره والعلاقات مع دوله الامارات منطقه
الزيارات التي قمنا بها الى هذه الدوله
الشقيقه
الامارات العربيه المتحده والتي اعتبرها
وطني الثانيه والوطن الثانيه للملايين من
الباكستانيين وانا ممتان جدا لقياده
الامارات العربيه المتحده واخص بالذكر اخي
صاحب السمو الشيخ محمد بن زايد الاخ المحب
والداعمه الكبير لباكستان حيث يحب ان
تتقدم باكستان وان يصعد ويزدهر شعبها وقد
قدم لنا سموه الكثير من المساعده من اجل
تحقيق ذلك ليس فقط خلال السنوات الاخيره
بل منذ ولاده الباكستان قبل 75 عاما خلال
عهد والده الراحل الشيخ زايد رحمه الله
واسكنه فسيح جناته الذي كان صديقا عظيما
لباكستان
من الجنه
استراتيجيه مهمه بالنسبه لدول المنطقه
وايضا لدول المنطقه اهميه اقتصاديه سياسيه
وبعض ديني وعمق ثقافي
يعني استنادا على هاتين الاهميتين كيف
يمكن ان تصف العلاقه مع دول المنطقه وكيف
يمكن ان تتطور هذه العلاقات في الفتره
المقبله
اسلاميه
بالتحديد الخليج العربي المجاور لدوله
باكستان تجمعه بنا علاقات قائمه على الثقه
المشتركه والاحترام المتبادل والدين
الواحد والثقافه والعلاقات التاريخيه على
هذا الاساس فان الباكستان وقياداتي دول
الخليج لديها واحده مشتركه وهي
التعاون فيما بيننا في مجالات التجاره
والاستثمار والثقافه والترويج دين الاسلام
على انه دين سلام وامن وبريء من انواع
التطرف كافه كل هذه المسائل وغيرها تصنع
باقه رائعه من الاجندات التي يجب ان نعمل
عليها معه وهذا ما يحدث بالفعل وبذلك
من الدول الشقيقه
في ذلك سواء من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
او الامارات العربيه المتحده ومن الاخرى
صديقيني وهذا لا يعني اننا يجب ان نتطلع
عن الحصول على العبات والهدايه من اشقائنا
الموفقين والمعتمدين هؤلاء
لا هذه ليست رؤيتي ولا ارى الامور بهذا
الشكل امه لديها اندفاع قوي والقدره على
الصمود والشجاعه
هي اننا معا الى جانب مساعده اخواننا هنا
فان شاء الله سنتمكن من الوقوف على
اقدامنا ونطور تجاره والاستثمارات لاننا
صحيح اخوه ولكن طلب المساعده باستمرار لا
ينعكس بشكل جيد على باكستان من اخواننا
رغم استعدادهم المستمر لتقديم المساعده
كما حدث يوم امس وهو مثال رائع على اخر
يقدم المساعده لاخيه الا اننا نريد ان
تتحول هذه المساعده الى تجاره واستثمارات
والمزيد من الرفاه الاقتصادي لتوليد
الثروه
لكي نتمكن من الوقوف على اقدامنا هذا هو
الطريق للمضيق قدومه وهذا هو سبب
الباكستان عن الهند
وان شاء الله
سيتحقق هذا الحلم
رئيس الوزراء بما انك تتحدث عن الهند
اليوم يعني من المعلوم ان العلاقه بين
الطرفين بين هذين البلدين المتجاورين
تاريخيا هي العلاقه متوتره كيف يعني تصف
العلاقه بينكم خصوصا وانك من اقرب رؤساء
الحكومات الذين مروا يعني بالسياسه
الباكستانيه الى الهند
اختي
هذا النكته مهمه جدا
اذا
اختي هذه النقطه مهمه جدا
الهند دوله مجاوره نحن جيران ولنتحدث
بصراحه حتى وان كانت هذه الجيران ليست
باختيارنا فانها ستبقى الى الابد وعلينا
الاختيار بين العيش بسلام
لقد تعلمت باكستان الدرس لقد خضنا ثلاث
حروب مع الهند وعواقب تلك الحروب او
نتائجها كانت فقط المزيد من البؤس
والبطاله والفقر
والملايين وهبطوا الى مستويات الادنى لقد
تعلمنا الدرس ونود ان نعيش بسلام مع الهند
بشرط حل مشكله الاساسيه وهذه مساله مهمه
جدا يا اختي
لذلك فان رسالتي الى القياده الهنديه
ورئيس الوزراء مودي هي لنجلس والله خذ
محادثات جده وصادقه لحل مسائلنا الملحه
مثل كشمير التي تشهد انتهاكات صارخه لحقوق
الانسان في كل يوم
تفضوا بكل اشكال الاستقلال التي منحوها
للكشميريين حسب الماده 270 من الدستور
التي قاموا بالغائها في عام 2019
لون مخوضه في التفاصيل لكن يكفي القول ان
هذا يجب ان يتوقف لكي نبعث برساله الى
العالم مفادها ان الهند مستعده للمحادثات
ونحن ايضا اكثر من مستعدين لذلك
نحن دوله لا تمتلك النفط او الغاز بل
لدينا الموارد البشريه القويه والقوه
العامله والمهندسون هذه اصولنا نريد ان
نحول ادواتنا لتصبح مصدر ازدهار ومن اجل
ذلك يجب استغلال مواردنا للتخلص من الفقر
والبطانه ولتوفير الادويه والتعليم الجوده
وغيرها وعدم هدر هذه الموارد على الذخائر
والقنابل هذه هي الرساله التي اود ان
اقدمها لمودي
واخيرا كلانا قوه النوويه ومسلحون لقدر
الله اذا اندلعت الحرب فمن سيحيا ليروي ما
حدث هذا ليس خيارا لقد طلبت من اخي صاحب
السمو الشيخ محمد بن زايد فهو اخو
لباكستان ولديه علاقات طيبه مع الهند
وبوسعه لاعب دور مهم جدا من جمع البلدين
على طويله المحادثه
وان اعطي كلمه شرف باننا سنتحدث مع الهند
بنوايا الصادقه لكن على البلدين ان يتحلى
انت مشكله رئيس الوزراء اسمح لي ان انتقل
الى فاصل قصير ونعود من بعد لمتابعه هذا
الحوار مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا بعد هذا
الفاصل بهذه المقابله الخاصه مع رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني ومع مواضيع هامه
داخليا وخارجيا ابقى معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا نعود لاكمال
هذه المقابله الخاصه مع رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني شهبه شريف اهلا بك حضره رئيس
الوزراء نعود لاكمال هذا الحوار تاريخيا
لحزب الرابطه الاسلاميه القدره في التعامل
مع الشرق والغرب في امن واحد وايضا
تاريخيا لاكستان القدره على التعامل ولها
دور بالتعاون مع الشرق والغرب ايضا على
نفس المستوى اليوم هل تعولنا على هذا
الدور التاريخي الذي حتى خلال الحرب
البارده يعني كان كان دور بارز باحداث
توازن بالطاعات مع القوهتين
اليوم العالمي منقسم بين هاتين القوتين هل
تعولنا على هذا الدور لاحداث توازن
بالتعاطي معاهتين القوتين
فايبر
هذا العالم تكمن في التعايش التوترات مثل
الحاصله في الشرق اوروبا تسببت في اثار
كارثيه على العالم كله انظري الى اسعار
السلع التي وصلت الى عنان السماء
والقمح التي ارتفعت اسعارها بشكل كبير
العالم كله يعاني بشكل كارثه ولولا الشتاء
الدافئ في اوروبا
الاشياء التي يعيشها المواطن الباكستاني
وبظل اتساع ال- الفجوه الماليه مع ارتفاع
اسعار النفط عالميا بما ان باكستان مستورد
اساسي للنفط كيف وما هي رؤيه شهبان شريف
اليوم للحل الاقتصادي داخل باكستان
نحن بلا شك نواجه تحديات الاقتصاديه صعبه
ولكن التاريخ المعاصر مليء بمثل هذه
الامثله فالامم متواجه التحديات والصعوبات
ولكنها التزمت لتقبل التحديات ووقفت في
وجهها وعملت جاهده ومن دون كللل وقدمت
التضحيات وتجاوزت قله تلك المشكله هناك
امثله حي عن ذلك انظري ما حدث قبل 75 عاما
عندما ابيدت المانيا بالكامل واليابان
بعدها هزيمتها الكامله
ما الذي حدث بعد 75 عاما عادت الى الافق
لتصبح من اسرع الاقتصادات العالميه نموه
هذا هو المثال الذي نضعه امامنا لدينا
تحديات ومصاعم واخوانه هنا في الامارات
العربيه المتحده ودول الاخرى الشقيقه
يقدمون لنا المساعده وان شاء الله
سنتجاوز هذه الصعوبه ولكن في الختام الامر
بدمائنا وعرقنا
الفساد داخل باكستان وهل ستقفون بوجه
الفساد المستشار داخل الباكستان
عام دراسمان
وانا اخره رجل يتسامح مع الفساد انا انسان
بسيط ولكن في الحكومه لا اتسامح مع مثلي
هذه الامور ابدا
اغلب الحكومات الباكستانيه لم تكمل مهام
الدستوريه كامله ولم تكمل وقت الدستوري
كامل ما عدا الحكومات المؤقته اليوم عبر
هذه الرؤيا المختلفه التي تعبر عنها هل
تتامل ان تكمل حكومه شباس شريف مهمتها
الدستوريه ومدتها الدستوريه
الباكستان
تحت العين همم تقريبا
ان شاء الله اذا الله راد ان انا نعمل
يعني من قوه ان شاء الله الاولى
اسمح لي حضرت رئيس الوزراء ان اختم مع هذا
السؤال الذي ساطلب منك لو سمحت ان تتوجه
فيه للمواطن الباكستاني اليوم الذي يتابع
شاشه قناه العربيه ماذا تقول للباكستانيين
الذين يرزحون اليوم يعني تحت وطاه الفقر
وبظل ازمه اقتصاديه خالقه بما ان الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه مترديه عالميا وطبعا في الداخل
الباكستاني
واخواتي باكستانيين
انظروا كيف حولت الامارات العربيه المتحده
تحت قياده الشيخ محمد بن زايد الرماله الى
ذهب وكيف اصبح المجتمع السعودي من اكثر
الشعوب العالميه ازدهاره تحت هذه القياده
الديناميكيه لاخي صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان
الشيء الاهم هو الالتزام والجهود المستمره
والتضحيات
الخطابات ملهمه ولكن الكلام يجب ان يتحول
الى عمل هذا كل شيء عند
حضرتك
معنا الليله على العربيه على شاشه العربيه
امم طبعا نتمنى السلام والازدهار لباكستان
بالسنوات المقبله وضمن ولاياتك شكرا لك
مشاهدينا الى هنا ناتي الى ختام هذه
المقابله الخاصه عبر قناه وشاشه العربيه
شكرا لحسن المتابعه والى اللقاء في
مقابلات خاصه اخرى
[موسيقى]